would you ever turn gumroad into like a
dow or any of these kind of new
structures like you're talking about
open source kind of methodology right
even though it's still a company from a
legal structure standpoint are you
thinking about this because it kind of
feels like that's the natural extension
is that you would say hey we're actually
going to open source code we're going to
create the economic structure incentive
around like these dows that people are
talking about like
what's what are you optimizing for or
where do you see this evolving to i
think so yeah i mean i think what what's
happening with dao's is that you know
and this is this is a thing that i've
seen
generally happening in software right
which is you build something you do what
you you you invent you know some new
product or technology you innovate um
there's sort of a lot of creative
disruption that's happening but you know
government's 10 years old we're still
innovating we're still doing a bunch of
stuff but i'm not making as you know
risky as risky bets i'm not you know
we're not launching new products all the
time and this is the case for tons and
tons of software businesses you kind of
solve the problem and maybe the best
thing to do is to kind of keep solving
the problem instead of trying to like
you know add features and and and charge
more and all these things that your
customers frankly don't really even want
you to do
um and so yeah i think i think extra
extricating yourself from the business
makes a lot of sense right and i think
about what do i actually need to do at
government like truly actually you know
need to do otherwise the gov otherwise
the business would would fail um as ceo
and there's really only
two or three things that
i have a google doc of this because i'm
trying to get it to zero and one of them
is i need to make sure there's enough
money in the in the bank accounts right
which might mean moving money from
strive to pay and then no one should say
that that's something a ceo should do
right like that should be purely
automated it's insane that i have to log
into wells fargo like it's stupid and so
that's obviously gonna get you know
automated at some point in the future um
the other thing is you know like sort of
tie breaking right like governance
effectively right which is like hey you
know should we roll back the site
because we have a bug is it bad enough
or not um should we de-platform this
creator for for posting this kind of
thing um you know a lot of these kind of
like decisions that that feel like only
i could make and i think a dow is like a
phenomenal
sort of way of thinking about those
sorts of things like if if 10 out of 20
employees at gumroad or whatever the
numbers may be um decide we showed or
should not do this or maybe the creators
on the platform right um they can decide
who else they want to be able to join
their community or not right like why do
i get to decide oh like this creator you
know uh offends you know my
sensibilities so that they don't get to
use gumroad or they don't get featured
on them like what you know these are all
the kind of opinions that you know
effectively just reflect the opinions of
the of the founders c of the company um
and so i could totally see a world in
the future i don't know exactly how we
get there um but i would dream to to
have government be a doubt to have
government be a place where i can just
empower people um to make their own
decisions um and then you know the and
then all and then obviously like i would
love the sort of liquidity of it too
right like i think what you know another
big issue you have with these companies
is you basically run this thing it gets
to like 10 million it's a great healthy
business but you don't you're not at
that scale to ipo you probably don't
want to
you also don't want to like fully
liquidate i don't want to sell gum right
entirely i don't want to sell it to
another business but i would love to
take a little bit of money off the table
right buy a house or or what have you
get into you know uh and to you know buy
some solana or whatever um and so i
would i think that krypton does also
solve this sort of problem whereas you
know you can kind of it's fully liquid
you can kind of take some money off the
table you can kind of delegate you know
your duties over time until you have
none left and then all of a sudden
just like a e s announced i think today
right like they're like they haven't
they're setting up a down and you know
boom you don't even have a company you
can you can shut down the company right
right now in this society we have visa
mastercard like what innovation is visa
mastercard really doing today i have no
idea but they're effectively charging a
three percent tax on the entire credit
card economy right hundreds of billions
of dollars a year
like why
right like what are like it just doesn't
make any sense but it's a skyscraper
we're building on top of this incredible
amount of infrastructure and maybe the
answer is that we don't destroy visa
mastercard but we just you know all of
the value gets accrued to all of the
stakeholders the company you got to get
this with public companies i guess you
know in in the us but
you know but going public is you know
should be a click of a button right
which and and effectively i think crypto
has that promise built into it right
which is i should be able to hit a
bottom boom there's now gum token
you know maybe the equity maps into this
token sale initially and then boom
you're like you know now this this place
votes and obviously a lot of the the
mechanics have to be moved on chain like
it wouldn't be you know how do we
de-platform all these sorts of things
would have to get there but i think
that's you know the writing's on the
wall in my opinion like it's it's gonna
happen i don't know if governor was like
too late maybe we won't be able to
switch governor to this new model but
certainly like a lot of the companies
frankly a lot of our competitors my
guess is that they're going to just
build you know with a lot of these
things just built in from the from the
beginning right